you have to deal with any annoying pests
in australia
require me yeah when you're getting the
border they're like oh i made do you
mind if the koala boats on your toe mate
i don't even think i've ever seen a
koala in the wild dude i want to see a
koala they're extremely rare in the wild
because they're so hidden but like uh my
house we used to have these like wasps
that flow around all the time um [ __ ]
how did you get rid of wasps you don't
like the last time i went home i
remember i was like my dad was like you
know son come and join me for a beer on
the in the balcony it's a nice stand i'm
like yeah sure i walk out and there's
like 20 wasps just flying around because
i was like uh father what there are a
lot of wasps flying around your face
right now and he's like yeah it's all
right that won't sting you i was like
okay
why do wasps exist like like do they do
anything good for anyone no
they are the they're the [ __ ] of
the internet
it's about so many creatures though but
like so a lot of creatures don't
actively try to like be [ __ ] and
sting you and like the thing is at least
are you judging an animal's worth based
on how annoying it is to people kind of
kind of yeah yeah okay
like what what what do wasps do for
nature because you know like bees they
make honey they pollenize flowers and
you know what at least nature had the
decency to nerf bees you know they they
get one shot one shot that's like that's
like their nuclear option man that's
like they're fighting
they can't reach the shelves i desire
i would be i would gladly be racist
towards wasps
all right well that's an out of context
i would like to be racist cut
no because uh yeah god's the kind of guy
where if you go to death note the first
thing he'd write is what what's this
everyone everything that annoys
everybody like a one by one one by one
by name every single one like a simple
one for like the death note it comes
back it's like sorry did not did not
spell correctly yeah i should preface i
actually have a phobia of bees and wasps
i don't know if i've ever thought you
could have told it okay you're stung in
the eye as a kid yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah i would i would have yeah
but the thing is the thing is like i've
grown like even though i like i'm
[ __ ] deadly scared of them i still in
my heart i still i still understand why
bees you know why bees are a thing i
think i think you know after after years
of conditioning like bumble bees they
look really kind of cute like they look
like like flurry and big and they
pollenize they're chonky yeah they're
chunkier
oh just give them a hug
have you have you taken any steps
towards trying to conquer your fear of
beings
um
we do like a fear fact dress kind of
thing where we have what would the steps
be though why don't we play dark souls
music right like
and then we bring up and gone your
punishment for the trash taste after
dark is that you have to put your head
in a box of bees
what was this fear factor
would you do that
if you told me if you told me if okay
here's the thing right i'm an idiot if
some guy came on he's probably he's
always australian because on every
single wildlife show where there's a
wildlife expert the [ __ ] is always
australian of course yeah he'll come on
and be like oh yeah they won't sting you
and then the 10 seconds later you're
like
you're like oh you're fine though you're
fine
you're gonna die don't worry yeah it
changes oh you won't die yeah yeah if if
uh if some wildlife expert told me that
it's safe to do it i'd do it
stick your head in the box
that's a big [ __ ] stuff i mean like
i don't know i don't know how much for
you to put your hand in a box of bees
how much how long how much are you
willing to pay me one minute one minute
one minute
uh what is the minimum price you'd do it
for 10.
i would gladly do it for like five
five yeah five five g's five g's yeah
ten g for me i don't know it would have
to be more than ten for me
i don't know maybe or maybe or maybe or
maybe just for content
[Laughter]
oh yeah
when you're back sweet advertising if
i'm just chilling in my living room and
you can't much you put your hand in the
box
and then they do it but if it's for
content i probably do it for free i mean
here's the thing right because before
like when i was a kid i couldn't even
look at like this i couldn't even look
at videos of bees like i'd see a bee and
i'd literally scream and like run inside
and like shut so we got yeah a box of
bees you would do it for content
how do we get how do they get a box
maybe how do they do you make an
audience
how do they do this on shows how do they
get a box of but like now what like i go
through phases where like maybe like out
of like a sense of like morbid curiosity
i like look at i look at bee cleaning or
like b videos on youtube right just
seeing like these beekeepers just
[ __ ] like scooping up like these pile
of bees yeah and just them casually
being like oh you know they're very
friendly today i've only been sung three
times like you've been stung three times
and that's it that's it i'd be [ __ ]
one time is more than more than enough
for me i wonder how many times would you
get stung if your hand was in that box
for a minute like a hundred bees i think
if you just stay still nothing probably
nothing
but if you're [ __ ] doing this yeah
yeah yeah this is uh
ignorant wolf uh what is it uh ignorance
yeah wolf legendary yeah but like
okay
bees maybe because uh bees maybe wasps
get the [ __ ] out i'm coming here with a
flamethrower
if you if you come here with wasps
because like like i thought how about we
put your hand in a box with a feral
hyena gun what do you have for a minute
one minute
for content
i know it's like i've also like been
glad have you ever seen a hornet as well
yeah um those are [ __ ] like
terrifying i think i've seen we have the
killer hornets here they have to kill a
horse yeah those are those i don't want
to [ __ ] with those those are scary those
are scary yeah especially like i
remember seeing the video of just like
hornet like
it sounds like a [ __ ] it sounds like
a [ __ ] anime fight or something it's
like hornets versus bees and this video
is epic
where the beast like surround it yeah
the beasts around it and like it's it's
not it's not even like a war it's a
massacre right because the hornet like
one hornets take takes down like [ __ ]
a hundred bees or something and it's
it's i feel like oh no the beast [ __ ] up
the hornet oh really yeah we've seen
different videos then because i've seen
from fights
i don't know which b it is but there's
videos where like there is a way that
they kill the hornet by
basically they all just compact
themselves on the hornet right and
they roll around and they do it like
with like such like energy that it
actually just burns the hornet alive
well like through friction yeah it like
kills the hornet by being so hot holy
[ __ ] that's that's [ __ ] metal
japanese japanese honeybees
they kill the japanese like they
surround it and they compact like a ball
and they roll and like keep like
suffocating it and wanting it the [ __ ]
it's so bad
i'm sure there'll be a clip on the
screen right now it's it's [ __ ] cool
it's so cool like nature a lot of times
it's just sounds like you're shown in
like
i just like love it that these bees
figured this out yeah they're like [ __ ]
it just throw it how did the bees figure
that i don't know right [ __ ] now you
ever heard of friction
i could use that yeah because like the
only video i've seen is where like it's
it's just these bees like this hive of
bees just [ __ ] chilling making honey
and then these [ __ ] group of ten
hornets or something just come on and
start like [ __ ] biting their heads
off massacre this entire hive and then
[ __ ] off i'm like jesus christ
we are like [ __ ] nature can be
[ __ ] metal sometimes because i
remember seeing this video not about
bees well i think it was like ants and
scientists would just were like would
they they were
studying fire ants because fire ants
have a way when they're moving in a
group or have
they they have
how i how can i word this when they're
what would you call like a group of ants
a colony like yeah a colony of ants the
way they
act and behave sometimes can
behave like a liquid and sometimes can
behave like a solid this is yes certain
ants i think not all yeah not all of
them i think
it was fire ants they can like cross
water by yeah bunching together yeah
and basically becoming kind of like a
pseudo-solid yeah okay and then they
like kind of like yeah so they can have
they like these ants can
have as a colony have properties of a
liquid or a solid
depending on the situation so dope and
they were like scientists was
literally studying them to try and apply
this to like real life metals and real
life real life applications like that
that sounds so [ __ ] humans become
liquid if we try harder
i'm so enjoying now soon i'll be a
liquid joey
i am i am solid joey but no yeah